we have between 800 and a thousand Funko
pops give or take um Anthony people's
I'm a Funko pop collector I'm filling
high five fantastic and I hope you are
as well
Funko pops are everywhere there are
those small plastic figurines with giant
heads and big round eyes
there are pops of pretty much every
character you can think of and fans are
obsessed the company did half a billion
dollars in sales in 2017 and has already
surpassed that in 2018 Anthony who goes
by the nickname geeky people's has taken
his obsession to another level
Funko fanatics is definitely a common
term that we all use to refer to
ourselves Anthony and his partner Raul
have been collecting tops since 2015 and
they can be found all over their home
they're displayed in all the various
places that we can find room in our New
York City apartment we have one room
that is our room that we've kind of
transformed into a pop then my DC wall
is dedicated to Batman the Animated
Series which is very important to me in
my childhood growing up I'm a big Marvel
boy so I collect a lot of the model
lives I have one wall dedicated to
Freddy Funko the Funko mascot the other
wall is kind of storage small process on
building the room up his kitchen is
decorated with pups that are
food-related a friend of mine he
actually displays his mr. freeze pops in
the freezer and when we visited in
October his living room was decorated
with Halloween related pops so all the
pops that are kind of horror based or
fun or scary and we also have pops
displayed in our bedroom
Anthony keeps track of his pops using
several online apps which estimate that
his collection could be worth thousands
of dollars based on market value but the
prices can change over time
his first pop was a storm figurine given
to him as a gift from friends and then
from there it just took fire inside of
me and I just wanted to collect as many
as I can I actually still have that
storm it's right there on the wall I
keep it right where I can always see it
his collection includes many rare pops
that were released as limited editions
including some ultra rare ones called
chase Pop's a chase pop is a pop that
you can find kind of like the golden
ticket that Willy Wonka was giving out
it's very rare and there's only a
certain limited amount of them and they
also have a special sticker on there
also like if you collect comics it's
like a variant cover in 2017 he went to
the grand opening of the Funko
headquarters in Washington and got his
hands on one of his most prized
figurines
it's the Emerald Freddy as the flagship
sticker on it which was also very rare I
also have another very rare pop the blue
chrome Batman from San Diego comic-con I
stuffed for four days in front of the
San Diego Convention and I ended up
getting into the booth I cried a lot
because I was so happy and so excited um
the chrome Batman is worth a lot of
money I've seen it go up right now
currently as high on eBay as $800 he and
his partner also placed in a lip-syncing
contest at a Funko event and chose to
giant Robin and Joker pops as prizes
that he estimates are now worth about
$1,200 each I do also have just a couple
rare proto pops these are basically
prototypes of pops before they're
mass-produced Anthony doesn't just
collect pops however he also organizes
events with fellow collectors including
fundraisers for charity I host here in
New York periodically events that are
that I call people's pop
swap those events have been major major
moments where I've gotten to meet so
many collectors and have so many
wonderful friends because of that in
addition to swapping Anthony often sells
pops to help fund his trips to various
conventions around the world to buy new
ones because it's very expensive
and the expenses do mount ah he's active
in the official Funko forum a message
board for fans so he always knows where
to be to get the rare pups for cheap I
try to get them as close to the retail
value that they come out for but he will
occasionally have to pay upwards of $100
for something that he missed to complete
a set he has a few basic tips for Funko
hunters so it's best to just be on your
game know your information know where
the pop is you want know how much it's
going to cost and be prepared to line up
and hopefully score some wonderful Funko
pops and he says he has no desire to
stop collecting anytime soon whether I
collect Funko pops are not do one thing
that is a current constant is that the
people I've met and the relationships
I've established from being in the Funko
pop community they're not going anywhere
in my heart I will keep in contact
whether I collect funcles enough and
there's a story behind each one some
people identify themselves as I'm Athene
and they'll be wearing the field patch
or they're fun characters Jersey Funko
and the Chicago Funko so many across the
country and they identify themselves
that way but we're all fanatics we're
all Funko fanatics